the single biggest lie in politics is
the lie that Republicans are the party
of the rich the the dirty little secret
is too rich too just fine with big
government big business does great with
big government they get in bed with big
government they have armies of lawyers
and lobbyists and accountants they carve
up all sorts of special rules to benefit
them take for example dodd-frank
dodd-frank was sold to the American
people as stopping the problem of too
big to fail now what's happened since
then the big banks have become bigger
because they put in massive regulations
that only the big banks can deal with
and the people who are being driven out
of business are the small banks the
community financial institutions and the
truth of the matter is that wasn't an
unintended consequence that was the
intended consequence you know President
Obama recently has been talking a great
deal about income inequality and I
welcome that I think it's great it's the
president's talking about income
inequality and in particular I'd like
him to address the undeniable reality
that income inequality has gotten
significantly worse under the Obama
administration that the Obama economic
agenda is exacerbating income inequality
right now today the top 1% the
millionaires and billionaires that the
president loves to demagogue earn a
higher share of our national income than
any time since 1928 the policies of this
administration out-of-control spending
and taxes and regulation are hammering
small businesses and the people who are
getting hurt they're not the titans of
industry if you were flying a private
jet five years ago you're still flying a
private jet the people who have been
hurt by the Obama economy have been the
most vulnerable among us they've been
young people Hispanics African Americans
single moms you know I try to look at
every policy issue from the perspective
of my dad 1957 washing dishes making 50
cents an hour my dad were washing dishes
today the odds are very very high he
would have lost his job because of the
crushing taxes and regulations that are
hammering small businesses two-thirds of
all new jobs come from small businesses
if my dad hadn't lost his job the odds
are overwhelmed
he would have had his hours forcibly
reduced to 28 or 29 hours a week because
the threshold for Obamacare is 30 hours
a week and he wouldn't have been able to
pay his way through the University of
Texas at 29 hours a week he wouldn't
have been able to feed his kids at 29
hours a week and if he doesn't have that
first job washing dishes he doesn't get
a second job working as a cook which
means he doesn't get his third job
working as a teaching assistant which
means he doesn't get his fourth job as a
computer programmer at IBM we need to be
focusing on how policies impact those
are struggling and every policy we think
about and talk about should focus on
making it easier for those who are
struggling to climb that economic ladder
and to achieve the American dream and
there is no policy that is more potent
in that regard than school choice
because it's about empowering kids
giving low-income kids giving Hispanic
kids giving african-american kids the
same ability to choose that the rich and
middle class have always had